- [Mark] All right, Kelly.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Kelly, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Kelly] Los Angeles, I
mainly grew up on the East side
and more so in foster
care, different cities,
but mostly LA, I was born in LA.
- [Mark] So you went to
foster home at what age?
- My first time ever going in foster care,
I was about two months and
it was because my mother,
had called DCFS on herself for abusing me,
I was told it was postpartum depression
on top of her already--
- [Mark] So your mum called
child services on herself?
- She called child services on herself,
because she would like abuse me,
my grandma told me stories,
how she would abused me as a baby.
I have pictures of me with
black eyes in two months
and so basically I got,
that's the first time
I ever got to go at two months
and then I got, my grandma got me.
- [Mark] Wow.
- But I was still in the system.
She got me, system-wise
- [Mark] Got it.
And how was your childhood?
Generally?
- It was pretty bad, but at the same time,
I was always the type of
person that tried to make,
I like to laugh a lot.
I laughed a lot, but my
childhood was pretty tragic.
I've been--
- [Mark] What kinda stuff, abuse?
- I've been abused, I've been raped,
I've been molested, I've been tortured.
- [Mark] At what ages?
- My first time ever
being raped, I was five.
- [Mark] By who?
- My foster parent.
He raped me and the foster mom, she knew,
but she never,
she didn't care, or that's
what it looked like.
That got proven in court,
me getting molested and raped at five
and then I got moved,
I've been at 24 different foster homes.
My grandma got me at two months in foster,
then she lost me, I
think I was around two.
So I was in foster care,
then my mom got me back.
She wanted me back.
- [Mark] Got it.
- And then she lost me again due to abuse,
she abused me again and she lost me.
I had whips everywhere, like everywhere,
purple whips everywhere
and then I got took away.
That's when I was in foster care
and my first time ever getting molested,
at least to my memory.
That's the first
recollection I could remember
and it's crazy with that recollection
because, that was something
that I always would remember
or think, I know exactly what happened.
I would always think
certain things to myself,
just on that particular
age, I would think,
'cause I know exactly what he did to me,
I remember him coming in the
door, I remember everything.
Me and my foster mom were
just watching a movie,
he walked in drunk,
he had a cup of alcohol in his hand,
he pretty much asked me to
come into the room or whatever
and with me being five years old,
I'm not expecting this or whatever.
He just grabbed me up
and covered my face and told
me to be quiet and just did it
and there was just blood
everywhere, I was screaming.
She came in, this is how
the police was called,
she came in and she was
like, "What are you doing?
What are you doing?"
He hit her,
but I guess I found out later,
that they had already history
of abuse problems in their relationship,
this is why she never cared
about him continuing to do it.
But like I said, I would
have memories in my head,
of certain things as I'm getting older
and I'm like, "Why would
I think these things,
if it didn't happen?"
So then I went back and asked my foster,
the caseworker.
She explained to me that all of this stuff
was actually documented
and stuff like that,
it's just crazy, it's like,
for a five years old getting--
- [Mark] Where'd your life go after five?
- Another foster home and that was good.
A few of my foster homes were
good, but then I would go to,
it'll be another foster
parent that likes to,
rape and molest, like, I was seven,
I don't know if you could
see these on my sides,
- [Mark] Yeah.
- but my foster dad, he actually
duct taped me to a chair
and he pretty much screw
drived screws in my ear
and then he pulled them out and...
- [Mark] He put screws?
- Screws
You know the small ones?
He screwed them with a screw gun.
He screwed them with a screw gun
and not all the way in,
but he's just a sick fuck.
He screwed them in my ears
and now I have permanent marks here.
They've been here ever since he did this.
- [Mark] He held you down or something?
- He duct taped me to a chair.
Duck taped me to a chair.
I was sitting in a a
wooden chair like this
and he duct taped me.
He used to chase me around
the house, to rape me
and I used to be running around the house.
He would lock his wife in the room
and he would chase me around the house,
I would be screaming for
help and saying ple--
- [Mark] This is your foster parent?
- My foster dad.
Yes, my foster dad.
He would chase me around
the house to rape me
and I would just scream and I would cry.
He would always catch me,
she never, after that one time she tried
and he hit her.
After that, that's when she
just started getting locked
in the room.
- [Mark] Wow.
- One day he raped me
so bad that I woke up,
I'll never forget, I had
on a Hannah Montana gown.
He raped me on the bathroom floor
and to the point where
I passed out, I woke up,
when I woke up, I was in
the bathroom by myself,
with a puddle of blood,
a whole puddle of blood.
- [Mark] At seven years old.
- Seven years old.
- [Mark] (chuckles) I'm afraid to ask,
where did your life go
after seven years old?
- After that, I think I went to a lady
and they'd pretty much
done that too and the more,
so abuse started happening,
more and more abuses,
like physical and verbal abuse.
It's like I would always say,
"I want my mom, I want my mom"
Oh, I went back to my mom, but
I did go to a foster parent
who she would like verbally
and physically abuse me.
I was out with my mom,
she would hit me and say,
"You're never going back to your mom"
and then I went back with my mom,
'cause she completed all of the
classes and stuff like that.
Went back with my mom
and then she abused me again.
Years passed 'cause I
didn't get taken away
till I was like, what 10?
And she abused me again, but
she had already been abusing me
throughout that time, but
not loud enough to the point
where the police are being called.
My mom would make me wear
turtlenecks even if it was hot,
I would have to wear turtlenecks
and I would have to wear
long pants, long socks,
everything would have to be
covered when I go to school,
because I would have whips and stuff,
These scars on my face,
around my eyes and stuff,
my mom, she threw a remote
at my eye when I was young
and it cut my eye to the point
where I had to go get stitches.
She pushed me into a
glass table and it broke,
I had got a cut on my eye for that too,
I'm not sure which eye
it is, I'll have to look.
My mom's, she has a mental problem.
So I've always just been in the system
and I've then I don't
know, it's a lot, a lot.
- [Mark] So eventually
you went out on your own
at some point?
- I ran away.
- [Mark] You ran away?
- I just ran away,
'cause I got sick of,
it felt like they weren't doing anything.
- [Mark] What age were you on your own?
- 11.
- [Mark] You ran away at 11?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Where'd you go at 11?
- I just ran away, I was...
That's when I started prostituting
- [Mark] At 11.
(Kelly nods)
- [Mark] What?
- Actually a guy, I met
a guy and he showed me,
that like I was running away,
and he found me and then he
started like having sex with me
and stuff, and then he just
showed me to prostitute.
Ever since I was from like 11,
until even now I prostitute,
'cause I don't have a job
and nobody will hire me,
I don't have my high school diploma,
I don't have any family, I
started doing cocaine at 11 too.
He showed me cocaine.
I stopped doing cocaine though,
because that's why I'm so small now.
I recently, I just did cocaine
but I started prostituting at 11.
I've been raped on the blade,
I've had a gun put up
to my head on the blade.
He tried to kill, he used to
abuse me, if I didn't wanna go,
'cause when I first did it,
it was kind of like fun to me,
but then when, I didn't know
that there was a such thing
as different sizes to penis.
When it gets bigger and
I don't know, I'm 11,
I don't know these things, it hurts.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- My body hurts, my everything is hurting
and stuff like that
and these guys are actually doing it hard,
they were, doing it hard to me.
(man shouts in the background)
- [Mark] It gets dangerous sometimes, huh?
- Yeah, and I would tell
him, "I don't wanna do it"
and he would beat me, beat
me to the point where,
my tooth is chipped here,
from him beating me.
He would give me--
- [Mark] This is your pimp?
- He was my pimp, that's what he--
- [Mark] Are you still with him?
- He told me, not now.
I stopped messing with him,
I wanna say earlier this year,
I was with him all this time,
he would abuse me, make
me go on the blade.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- 21.
- [Mark] 21.
- So not too long ago that
I stopped messing with him,
I had to run away from him
because he wanted to, he
took me like state to state
and so he took me to another country.
I don't, is Mexico
considered another country?
- [Mark] Yeah, it is.
- That's fucked up that I
even have to ask you that,
'cause I didn't get a lot of schooling.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- So, he took me
to Mexico and this guy,
he Mexican guy he raped me
and he came inside of
me and I got pregnant.
- [Mark] You weren't using condoms or?
- [Kelly] He told me not to, for that one.
He regulated all of the, everything.
- [Mark] Really?
- [Kelly] He regulated if I
use a condom or no condom,
he talked to the guys, I
didn't talk to the guys.
So I got pregnant, (sighs)
and I went full term with the pregnancy,
the baby died in some way, somehow.
When I thought I was
going to have the baby,
but it was a stillbirth.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- [Kelly A Stillbirth,
the baby was dead and so
that's really what made me,
leave him because that was
recent, that I had a stillbirth
and that I was raped by
that Mexican guy in Mexico.
That really fucked me up,
because it's like, I'm,
I don't know, it's...
- [Mark] And so you're
down here at Skid Row now?
- Now I came to Skid Row.
- [Mark] You're in a tent?
- Mhm, I stay in a tent out here,
because I don't want him to,
I'm scared he's gonna find me.
- [Mark] Are you using any
drugs that are out here?
- I tried the pookie, crystal,
but
I really don't wanna do it,
'cause I don't wanna fuck myself up,
but I'm more so starting back on cocaine,
but I did try, just
recently tried crystal.
That shit's crazy, that shit makes you...
I was walking around the street naked.
- [Mark] Really?
- (nods) By the refresher there,
they had to, the police came and got me.
I went to jail for that.
- [Mark] For walking around naked.
- And I was high off crystal.
- [Mark] I've seen girls walk
around naked, quite a bit.
- It was my first time
doing it, I went to jail
and (chuckles) I got a DA reject,
but I still went to jail for
it, it's still on my record.
That's fucked up but now--
- [Mark] Do you have any family?
Do you have contact with
your mom or anybody?
- No. (nods)
- [Mark] You're just on your own?
- I don't have anybody.
- [Mark] You do.
- Nobody, but God, I don't have anybody,
that's why I have to sell, prostitute.
To get by and on the County,
that's all I have is the County
and my fucking tent and God
and tricks, that's all I have.
Nobody cares about me, nobody loves me,
nobody checks on me, nobody
calls my government phone.
I don't know who the fuck
my dad is, (chuckles)
I don't know my dad's
family, I don't know.
I just try to be strong,
'cause I'm just trynna get it together,
'cause I don't wanna be out
here for the rest of my life,
I really don't.
I've been through too
much, I used to cut myself.
I stopped cutting myself
because I was just like,
"I have to be strong".
I cut myself so bad right
here, to the point where...
And right here and I almost died.
- [Mark] How long ago was that?
(car hoots) (child screams)
- I wanna say,
a couple of months ago
and they took me to a psych ward for it.
I was in the psych ward for like a month
and they were prescribing
me pills, Xanax for anxiety.
They're prescribing me just a
lot of Xanax to make me sleep
and Seroquel and anger drugs,
because like I get really angry,
that's one thing I get
really, really, really angry
and I don't know how to control myself,
'cause I feel like "Why the fu...?"
And I tried to kill myself,
'cause it's I feel like it's
no point of me being here,
if I don't have anybody.
- [Mark] Do you have any hopes
and dreams of doing anything else in life?
- I wanna go to school,
I wanna learn more,
I wanna be a lawyer.
I wanna do cosmetology,
but I don't know if I can,
because I haven't been to
school since I was 11, 10.
- [Mark] So you never went to high school?
- Never been to high school,
that's so embarrassing to say.
- [Mark] No.
- I've never been to high school,
all I know is the streets.
I got put on gang banging, prostitution,
that's really all I know and stealing,
stealing what I need, I
would never rob somebody.
I would just, that he, my pimp,
he would just make me go sell myself.
But when I ran away from him,
I would go steal some stuff
and prostitute too, but
more so steal stuff,
but he would always find me.
Police?
I always have, every time
I see the police, I run,
'cause like you said, I look young.
Just imagine how young I looked
when I was 11, 12, 13, 14.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I always had to run from the police,
when he took me to Mexico,
I was in the trunk the whole time.
- [Mark] He hid you in the trunk?
- In the trunk.
I couldn't even ride in the car.
He didn't want any police
to pull over and see me.
- [Mark] Wow.
- Okay, so I tried to kill
myself yesterday, right?
I took a whole bunch of Xanax pills,
'cause I get them prescribed
to me every month,
from being in the psych
ward, I get prescribed them.
I tried to, I took a whole bunch of pills,
the only reason why I'm
here, I'm pretty fucked up,
'cause it's Christmas time
and I don't have anybody like nobody.
So I just wanted to kill myself
and he made me throw up all of the pills,
like all of them, he gagged me,
until I threw up all of the pills.
Just imagine if he wouldn't
have came in when he came in,
I wouldn't even be here today.
- [Mark] Superman.
- (nods) Him.
- [Mark] That's who we called, yeah.
- If he wouldn't have been
there, came in when he came in,
I would have died.
- [Mark] Yeah, he's a good guy.
- I wouldn't be here to
even tell you my story,
that was weighing heavy on my heart,
the fact that I'm here today, because--
- [Mark] When you're thinking
of trying to kill yourself,
why is that?
'Cause you don't see
hope, you don't see...
- I felt, "What am I here for?"
- [Mark] No one loves you?
- Nobody loves me,
nobody cares about me, nobody...
Like I told you, nobody checks on me,
nobody does anything for me.
I've been selling my vagina,
since I was 11 years old
and before that I got raped treacherously,
molested treacherously,
abused, tortured treacherously.
My, I don't even like
to show my body to him,
because my foster dad, the one that rapes,
first started raping me,
he made me shave my vagina
when I didn't even have pubic hair,
he would cut me, cut me, cut me,
so around my vagina, I have...
I had to go and it's documented,
I had to get stitches all in my vagina
because he would be on
sherm when he was raping me,
and he would, he would cut me,
so that's why there was puddle of blood,
because he had cut me
with the razor all up,
cut me all up, cut me all up
and I had to go get stitches
for that on my vagina,
at a young age, I had to
get my vagina stitched up.
Now my vagina is damaged,
because of what he did
to me at a young age.
I don't even feel comfortable
showing anybody my body,
my lower body.
I hate myself because of
everything that I've been doing,
I just feel like, I'll probably
try to kill myself today,
especially, probably tomorrow,
because tomorrow's Christmas
and
I don't have anybody.
I'm not even gonna get to eat any food.
- [Mark] I'm gonna bring you
Christmas dinner tomorrow,
so you have to not kill
yourself, all right?
(chuckles) I'm gonna bring
your Christmas dinner tomorrow.
Can I do that?
- (nods) Yeah.
What time?
- [Mark] I'll be here,
two o'clock, something like that?
- 2 pm?
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm gonna bring you dinner.
- Okay, here?
- [Mark] Here,
I think I know where you...
You show me where your
tent is, I'll roll up.
- Okay.
- [Mark] We'll figure out a place to meet.
- [Mark] I'm not going
to let you kill yourself.
- Okay
- [Mark] Not on my watch.
(chuckles) Not a day after
you and I met, all right?
- (sighs) I'll try.
- [Mark] I'll give you a reason,
to not kill yourself tonight.
(chuckles)
I'm gonna bring you a nice
Christmas dinner tomorrow.
- I want some food too.
- [Mark] And a present.
- Okay.
- [Mark] You got a present.
- You promise?
- [Mark] I promise.
I'm a man of my word, (chuckles)
you ask anybody out here.
- Okay.
- [Mark] I'm a good guy.
- [Mark] I'm not up to no good
when I tell you I'm gonna be here,
it's gonna rain tomorrow,
I'm gonna be here.
- Okay.
- [Mark] All right?
I don't think we're done yet, (chuckles)
I think you and I are gonna
be talking for a while.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I
definitely wanna come back
and finish telling you everything.
- [Mark] I think you probably
have a lot more to share too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mark] All right, I gonna let you go
and I will see you tomorrow.
- Okay, I'll see you
tomorrow at two, here.
- [Mark] Two o'clock, right here.
- Okay.
- [Mark] I'm bringing you
Christmas, trees.(laughs)
- Okay.
- [Mark] Okay.
Thank you for coming by.
- No problem.
- [Mark] All right.